T
TRACE GALLAGHER OR "FOX NEWS
@ NIGHT" ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
TIME TO SHINE OUR FRIDAY NIGHT
LIGHT ON THE HIGHS AND LOWS OF
MEDIA COVERAGE OVER THE PAST
WEEK.
LET'S BRING IN SENIOR COMMUNIST
RACHEL BOVARD AND FORMER
COLORADO REPORTER STEPHANIE
HAMEL.
YOU FIRST.
YOUR HIGH IS THAT SOMEBODY ON
MSNBC FINALLY HAD THE TEMERITY
TO STAND UP AGAINST THE FALSE
NARRATIVE THAT BLACK PEOPLE ARE
BEING DENIED THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
HERE IS THE BACK AND FORTH AND
I'LL GET YOUR RESPONSE.
>> THEY BELIEVE THE 2024
ELECTION WILL BE OF FREE AND
FAIR ELECTION OF BLACK PEOPLE
ARE DENIED THE VOTE --
>> BLACK PEOPLE ARE BEING DENIED
THE RIGHT TO VOTE?
BLACK PEOPLE -- THE VOTE HAS
BEEN TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM?
>> BLACK VOTERS ARE BEING
DISENFRANCHISED IN AMERICA --
>> IT'S RAISING THE EXISTENTIAL
STAKES!
>> THE MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL,
THEY TOOK THE ALL-STAR GAME AWAY
FROM ATLANTA BECAUSE OF THEIR
VOTING LAWS AND NOW WE SEE
RECORD VOTING, RECORD EARLY
VOTING IN GEORGIA.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THAT'S WHAT WAS REALLY
REMARKABLE ABOUT THIS EXCHANGE
BUT YOU DON'T SEE TOO MANY
POINTS OF LIGHT OUT OF MSNBC
THESE DAYS BUT THIS WAS ONE OF
THEM.
HE ACTUALLY CALLED HIM OUT ON
THE LIE THAT SOMEHOW BLACK
PEOPLE CAN'T VOTE IN AMERICA AND
ESPECIALLY WITH GEORGIA WHEN YOU
SEE RECORD AFRICAN AMERICAN
TURNOUT.
JUST INCREDIBLE AND GOES ON
LATER TO SAY WILL YOU ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION IF DONALD TRUMP OR
REPUBLICAN WINS AND YOU HAVE
MEHDI HASSAN NOT KNOWING WHAT TO
SAY.
IT'S A REMARKABLE EXCHANGE.
>> Trace: YOU ARE CALLING YOUR
HIGHLIGHT, CNN CALLING A LIE
WHERE JOE BIDEN SAID GAS WHEN HE
WAS INAUGURATED WAS $5 A GALLON
AND THE WHOLE WORLD KNOWS IT WAS
NOT.
IT WAS $2.99 A GALLON.
SORRY!
$2.39 A GALLON.
EVEN WORSE!
GO AHEAD.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, B5.
THIS WAS DEFINITELY A PIG FLYING
MOMENT FOR ME WHEN I SAW THAT
CNN POLITICS ACTUALLY REPORTED
ON THIS BECAUSE I HEARD THE
PRESIDENT'S REMARKS YESTERDAY
HAPPENED IN SYRACUSE, NEW YORK.
WHEN HE SAID THAT GAS WAS $5 A
GALLON BEFORE HE TOOK OFFICE AND
WHEN HE TOOK OFFICE I WAS LIKE,
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I WENT ONLINE TODAY IF ANYBODY
BOTHERED TO REPORT ON IT.
HARDLY ANY NEWS OUTLETS TOUCHED
ON IT.
BECAUSE FOXES AND AFRAID OF
FACTS, BUT WHEN CNN HAD AN
ARTICLE ON IT I WAS LIKE, WELL
MET, THEY ARE TELLING THE TRUTH
FOR ONCE.
IT REALLY DOES MATTER WHEN THE
PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT AN
ISSUE THAT SO MANY AMERICANS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
GAS PRICES AND INFLATION?
WE EXPECT ACCURACY FROM HIM AND
EXPECT MORE IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA TO REPORT ON IT.
>> BY THE WAY, SPEAKING OF LOWS,
YOURS WAS THE RESPONSE TO
ELON MUSK TAKING OVER TWITTER.
HERE'S A COUPLE OF SAMPLES PER
HERE'S IS A TECH COLUMNIST
WEEDING "IT'S LIKE THE GATES OF
HELL OPENED ON THIS SIGHT
TONIGHT.
."
"THIS IS AN EMERGENCY.
TWITTER IS TO BE TAKEN OVER BY
THE EVIL SITH LORD."
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> UNBELIEVABLE AND IT'S
SOMETHING OF A RORSCHACH TEST
FOR HOW YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
ELON MUSK TAKING OVER TWITTER.
THESE PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND
FREE SPEECH.
WHEN THE FREE SPEECH ON A FLAT
FORM IS THREATENING DEMOCRACY
YOU ARE REALLY GETTING IT
BACKWARDS.
THE MASK COMES OFF FOR THEY
THINK THEY ARE OWNED TWITTER
BECAUSE THEY ARE UPSET THEIR
SACRED SPACES BEING INVADED.
IMPRESSIVE STATE OF JOURNALISM
WHEN YOU WATCH THESE KIND OF
RESPONSES TO FREE SPEECH GETTING
FREER ON TWITTER ON TWITTER.
>> STEPHANIE, YOUR LOW IS
APPARENTLY OVER AT MSNBC THEY
MUST BE PAYING A TON OF MONEY
BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS ALWAYS
WONDERFUL OVER THERE.
YOUR FINAL THOUGHTS?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
MY MEDIA LOGOS TO STEPHANIE RULE
ON HER PANEL WHERE THEY ARE
GASLIGHTING THEIR VIEWERS ABOUT
THE ECONOMY.
TRYING TO PRETEND THE POTENTIAL
VOTERS FOR HAVING THE AUDACITY
FOR VOTING REPUBLICANS WITH HOPE
THAT MAY BE THE INTERNET WOULD
BE A BETTER -- HE WENT ON TO
INSIST THAT EVERYTHING IS FINE
WITH THE ECONOMY.
THESE TV PEOPLE WANT YOU SAY
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING, THE
REALITY THAT YOU ARE FACING
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
INFLATION IS CRAZY.
THE LIST GOES ON.
IT'S REALLY OFFENSIVE.
THEY ARE EITHER IN ANNOUNCER
NATE UNIVERSE WHERE THEY ARE
BEING DISHONEST